so I said I said in the first film about
the
splitting of the two directions of the
hips the hips going this way the can
going that way
so I'd like to show you from some angles
you want mind to embodied to work
together so the the weapon is just a
training aid for you to learn better
timing and to improve your targets
all right it's not look it's a piece of
wood it's not a sword you can
class at a sword if you wish for ethical
reasons it's it's a training aid okay so
you've got the fingers in you've got the
Gap in between your hands
and what you can do is you can just
start off
try to get the first sliding
the same time
back and forth back and forth
notice my hips
my hair said I'm turning as I said
earlier they're not twisting they're not
turning what I've got to get used to is
as this last part comes down and the
foot I've got the heel up I'm gonna
check the power of this
so I'm trying to first get the timing
with the hands and the sword okay and
then it's installed
and installed feet and hands feet and
sword feet and sword for your hands so
they'd hand saw
and so on
and build up that that swinging of the
king
okay
so we'll get to them
[Music]
no it's my hips
I'm not really doing anything
I'm trying to get the foot
heels are referred to end at the same
time
this is
um I said in the first film about
photosynthesis saying Tony please
develop Ken and Joe
I was quite taken back by this but he
developed it for most sense it didn't he
changed it as far as the 31 anti-card to
human though since he told him I have
made the 31 Carter you now go and make
the anticharter to it so the Masters are
giving us challenges
to build improve on what they gave us
and what they started as long as it's
kept within the other thing that he said
back in 1940 there was as low as it
keeps within budo it is corrected so as
long as it Marshall
and it will protect you whatever you
decide to do and it's not weakness it's
not going to create a weakness and it's
not just a piece of we'll say flashing
you can or Joe work just to look good
would it work in a real situation and
would it allow you to be the winner and
I say winner and I don't mean it in an
ego winner I mean it in more let's save
you and those around you if you had to
use it so this is what I've progressed
over the many many years to do this
footwork and get a timing so when the
foot the hands to the end point so does
the cap
of showing you
so I'm thinking about those set and then
count
step and count
I'm asking you to use your common sense
because I decided that my body is out of
sync with my mind and my time I don't
have any time
unless I do this
but it's taken me
many years
to get to this okay
I I
okay
you decide some people doesn't say this
step can't
step
count
I don't like that and I've decided if
you want to follow me at my
instructional at least try after a few
years decide whether it's a morning
Carol donation but not
again watch my hips
watch my hands they don't go
like this
and don't charm
if you can like that the body starts
doing this and the upper body starts
turning the front of the foot starts to
go in the wrong place
and all sorts of
twisting is added that shouldn't be
added
spice
trigger fingers
[Applause]
okay so you start off
like shaking salt out of the solid pot
Shake
shake
shake shake shake shake shake
shake shake
[Music]
I hope you found love interest